jean-claude juncker is seen in Brussels
as a deal maker his presidency at the EU
Commission comes to an end on the 31st
of October the same day as Britain this
Jew to leave the EU and it's clear that
he doesn't want his legacy to be shaped
by No Deal
exit negotiations have been going on for
more than two years Teresa may often cut
an isolated figure in the depths of
talks with her European counterparts I
had a meeting with Paula Johnson the
Prime Minister this was a rather
positive meeting although the British
press was reporting it in the other way
we can we can have a deal do you think
we can get a deal I think you think that
the chances are more than 50/50 I don't
know but I'm doing everything to have
deal because I don't like the idea of no
dealer because this would have
catastrophic consequences it's better
and for Britain and for the European
Union to have a an organised was drowned
out by protests when he met John call
Juncker for the first time in Luxembourg
earlier this week
today the British government confirmed
they'd said the EU written documents
with some of their plans in a bid to
break the impasse have you received them
what are you receive we have received
some documents yesterday night I had no
chance no opportunity to take them on a
meditation what I will do this tonight
as far as the so-called alternative
arrangements are concerned allowing US
and Britain to achieve the main
objectives of the backstop I don't have
a neurotically relation to the back ship
that's the base table but if the results
are there I don't care about the inside
so the back okay
if the objectives and then if the
objectives are met all of them then we
don't need the backstop because anyway
backstop was a guarantee instrument and
not an instrument a name by itself
what we're here in the UK is that one of
the ideas is for Northern Ireland to
follow EU rules on food and agriculture
and then for other checks to be done
away from the border do you think that's
a basis of a deal is a basis you think
that's a starting point starting and
there over what Boris Johnson has
repeatedly promised he'll take the UK
out of the EU Deal or No Deal on the
31st of October
but despite Parliament saying he can't
without a deal mr. Juncker seems
incredibly certain the UK is heading for
the exit door and do you think there is
a chance that breaks that might not
happen
that's not my scenario I am convinced
that the brexit will happen you think
it's going to happen I think so
people have been negotiating here for
over two years and with the brexit
deadline fast approaching insiders have
been pretty gloomy about the chances of
striking a deal but speaking to John
claw Juncker today it quickly became
clear that he not only wants an
agreement but things were as possible
the question is are others convinced
that the compromises needed to strike an
agreement are acceptable with less than
six weeks to go despite the warm words
today there are still a long way to
travel before striking a deal
safety Ridge Sky News Brussels